je casse des cailloux sous le soleil
brûlant je me suis battu contre la loi
est la loi a gagné j'avais besoin
d'argent parce que je n'en avais pas
j'ai quitté ma copine je me sens mal
j'imagine que les dés sont jetés elle
était la meilleure fille que j'ai jamais
rencontré je me suis battu contre la loi
est la loi a gagné j'ai braqué des gens
avec ainsi coup je me suis battu contre
la loi est la loi a gagné j'ai perdu ma
poupée et ma joie je suis battu contre
la loi est la loi a gagné
les clashs
1977 génériques
mais où
femmes
salut à tous cette émission s'adresse
une fois de plus à toutes les personnes
détenues à tous les personnels
pénitentiaires à tous ceux qui sont
enfermés dans leur appartement ou dans
leur maison par tout ici et qui aimerait
bien comme chacun d'entre nous pouvoir
sortir on pense à vous dans les murs
mais bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
alors oui non oui alors ça change cette
semaine puisque les deux étoiles de la
cuisine maintenant d'où viennent de
marseille oui de riz ou bien les deux
équipes nationales de basket us et 3
contre 3 eh bien ils sont dirigés par ce
monsieur il ya aussi cette histoire des
deux seins de kate middleton tu te
souviens c'était à la une de la presse
people et bien les deux seins on était
défendu par cet avocat trop de gens oui
non mais cette semaine deux artistes
s'il te plaît 2 oui un temps des paroles
de l'ombre et un pour le live
non le tour de 208 doué c'est doux nom
seydoux pas c'est tout seydoux le
contraire de dur
je pense aux gens seuls
partis goût de vous
j'espère pas tout le monde dans une
solitude
confiné avec cette menace invisible
du lieu
vous partez dans combien de temps
cinq minutes
je peux mettre à votre place et faire
une interview
grands gourmands grand seigneur n'est il
n'aura pas tous tma ou tarn quelques
peluches ou think you may think et
houston 4 cabines celui patois gascon
que je chante quand je prends le bus
toujours non c'est parce que on va dans
les landes et que j'ai rendez vous avec
christelle drouet bonjour christelle
daunay bonjour vous êtes la directrice
de la prison de mont-de-marsan dans les
landes comment se passe le confinement
pour vous et nous on a beaucoup de
chance parce que parce qu'on est dans
une région très peu touchée par le cos
vide il ya aucun cas torche et personnel
que chez les personnes détenues et puis
on est dans un établissement qui est pas
sûr encombré
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on peut parler de prison
modèle à mont de marsan je dis ça parce
qu'il n'ya pas de surpopulation chez
vous que les cellules sont doublés mais
elles ont été prévues pour ça qu'à une
douche dans chaque cellule c'est un
établissement très récent il a un petit
peu plus de dix ans donc donc oui c'est
les dernières constructions qui
permettent tout ça oui chez vous il
existe ce qu'on appelle le module de
respect qu est ce que c'est vous nous
raconter ta en fait une modalités de
fonctionnement dans la détention sur
quatre bâtiments on en a deux qui
fonctionne comme ça un module de respect
les personnes détenues contractualisant
fait finalement le fait de respecter
autrui de respecter les règles en
échange de quoi il ya une liberté de
mouvement sur sur le bâtiment il ya des
activités qui peuvent être proposées par
les personnes détenues et puis il ya
aussi cette contrainte pour les
personnes détenues pas d'être d'être
relevé tous les matins à d'avoir 25
heures d'activités par semaine de
s'engager véritablement dans dans un
processus de réinsertion ils sont en
liberté comment les personnes détenues
elles sortent de leur cellule cantal
bonne oui à partir de l'ouverture le
matin jusqu'à là jusqu'à la fermeture le
soir et puis il ya une heure le midi où
ils sont fermés mais tout le reste du
temps tout est ouvert de la cellule
jusqu'à la cour de promenade sur
l'intégralité du bâtiment depuis combien
de temps il a été mis en place
le module de respect il est en place
depuis 2015 et ça a changé quoi ce
module de respect c'est une vraie
avancée parce que parce que en laissant
investi on les sent acteurs de leur
détention par exemple la sueur sur le
confinement on aurait pu fermer ces
secteurs en relisant vente si jamais on
est atteint mais alors en fait le
respect des gestes barrière est devenu
une condition pour rester au sein des
modules de respect il veut en demander
des produits pour nettoyer leurs
serrures de porte pour pour tout
nettoyer tout le temps toute la journée
pour pour éviter de propager le virus à
l'intérieur face et d'un respect des
règles du jeu qui est particulièrement
aiguë qui vraiment mérite d'être salué
et de murs en plexiglas à l'intérieur
des parloirs entre les gens pour qu'ils
puissent au moins se voir que les
parloirs puissent reprendre
je suis pas certaine que les personnes
détenues à
apprécier rond ce dispositif là aussi je
porte leurs paroles qui n'ont pas pris
dans leurs bras leurs enfants ou leurs
conjointes admettre de ne pas pouvoir
serrer dans ses bras sa famille je pense
que ce sera quelque chose de très très
difficile à faire passer et si les
parloirs ne rouvre pas le 11 mai combien
de temps est-ce tenable encore sans
parloir au président de la république
vers la donner une échéance il
n'attendrait pas que cette échéance soit
pour repousser très clairement merci
beaucoup christelle merci infiniment et
indifférence caniche est alors
lancée paroles de l'ombre
donc restez chez vous
non c'est pas non c'est pas nécessaire
non en fait c'est un mytho c'est un
mytho parce que
milton quoi j'ai pas sûr que mitonné
mitonnait mitovy alors cette semaine
c'est un mytho alors je ferai comme ça
cette semaine
cet ami taux qui lie les comptes rendus
de lecture évidemment dans les murs vous
vous n'avez pas forcément internet vous
n'avez pas forcément vu c'est la 1ère
oeuvre qui donne ça donc la halle
extrait par
[Musique]
copie
contraintes des lectures avec
l'excellent jonathan cohen et maintenant
je vous dévoile les dessous
[Applaudissements]
alors bonjour c'est jonathan cohen et je
vais dire
une fiche de lecture
d'un détenu dont alors je serai pas non
et c'est une lecture sur le film et le
livre wild
donc je suis très content de de lire
cette lettre
fin du mois cette fiche de lecture
alors
après avoir vu le film wild ya quelques
années j'étais ravi et impatient de lire
le livre
j'ai dévoré en deux jours j'ai pas pu me
détacher de l'histoire avec un plaisir
certain à voyager au côté de chez ruland
bien plus fluide randonnée elle chemine
dans sa propre histoire au plus profond
de ses peurs ses angoisses ses émotions
pour enfin se révéler
son histoire m'a beaucoup touché car mon
introspection entamé depuis mon
incarcération m'a fait voyager dans des
paysages désertiques où plane et la mort
et dans aussi les paysages chaleureux et
bienveillant habité par l'amour ou au
fil de mes pérégrinations j'ai fini par
reprendre contact avec moi même
j'ai appris à accepter à me détacher de
cet amour maternel nocifs
étouffant qui empêche de soi
j'ai appris à reconnaître que les
parents malgré leurs efforts ne sont pas
parfaits et ainsi j'ai appris à les
pardonner
j'ai appris à reconnaître mais
dysfonctionnements mes erreurs mais
insuffisances pour continuer à avancer
à travers l'histoire de chiril on
ressent la souffrance qui finit par se
transformer en violence
la maltraitance de son corps la
dépression le refus du bonheur l'image
négative de soi mais lorsqu elle
s'autorise ouvrir les yeux et reprendre
contact avec elle même
sa vie bascule et elle se libère
il ya bien pierre qui lumière d'une
prison
l'enfermement intérieur l'inhibition des
émotions la vraie liberté souvent plus
profondes
j'aimerais finir sur la phrase qui
conclut le livre si proche de ce que je
ressens
un ciel et la vie comme toutes les
villes
mystérieuse irrévocable et sacré
si proche si présente des signes n
c'était tellement bon de lâcher prise
voilà fin de la lecture
une fiche de lecture qui me touchent
tout particulièrement parce que
parce que je me retrouve aussi dans dans
ce long voyage que peut être la vie
et surtout de deux c'est parfois de ces
poids lourds dont il faut se délester
pour pouvoir avancer pouvoir se trouver
soi-même voilà s'affranchir de son passé
de séparemment de
de tout ce qui nous constitue mais qui
parfois peut nous
nous empêcher des toits pour ça que je
suis très content de faire cette lettre
très content d'avoir lu surtout et bunge
ou celle fort
[Applaudissements]
quelle grande voix va le surprendre
cette semaine quelle robe noire avance
dans le couloir du progrès qui va nous
surprendre
bonjour jean veil bonjour moi merci
d'être avec nous comment allez vous je
vais aussi bien que possible dans une
situation qui est compliquée pour tous
les français et enfin d'ailleurs pour
tous les êtres humains qui sont planète
le principe de la présence et punir et
réinsérer vous le dit que ça ne
fonctionne pas non ça marche pas ça
parce pas pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce qu'on est trop de gens en prison à
l'heure actuelle doit y avoir 71 1000
détenus 60000 places jean l'entourent de
15 cents personnes qui dorment par terre
c'est une situation qui est intolérable
mais je suis assez contente de pouvoir
d'avoir été invité par vous aujourd'hui
pour en parler parce que les français
peuvent se rendre compte de ce que et la
prison le confinement qu'ils vivent au
quotidien eux mêmes ça permet
d'appréhender un peu mieux peut-être les
difficultés que vivent les détenus et
les personnels pénitentiaires en de
surcroît
organiser le confinement et organiser la
sécurité pour les uns comme pour les
autres c'est ce sont des situations
pénibles et je plains
[Musique]
l'administration pénitentiaire d'avoir à
gérer cela maître veil dans les années
50 c'est une autre veille simone votre
mère qui a fait beaucoup pour la
question sanitaire en prison est ce que
comme votre mère l'était il faut être
militant de la condition humaine partout
tout le temps oui je crois que c'est
très important
elle avait appris beaucoup au moment de
son adolescence sur ce qu'est
l'enfermement
et la peur donc
je pense que ce sont des problèmes avec
lesquels ils étaient familières je crois
qu'elle a beaucoup fait que ça l'à
beaucoup passionné et puis
regardez beaucoup notamment le sort des
femmes mais pas seulement un conseil de
lecture pour tous ceux qui sont dedans
personnels pénitentiaires et personnes
détenues on peut lire le comte de monte
cristo et la manière dont edmond dantès
après l'abbé faria s'est évadé du
château d'if et puis on peut dire des
choses plus sérieuses comme par exemple
surveiller et punir de foucault ou
d'autres d'autres livres sur ce qu'est
la prison ce que ça représente alors
c'est moins gai et c'est je crois tout à
fait intéressant et ça permet de prendre
conscience de ce que peuvent être les
sanctions et la manière dont ils sont
appliqués dans nos pays même
démocratiques et où en principe
les droits sont respectés grâce à la
constitution et à la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme à quoi
s'accrocher quand on est dans et hors
les murs jean veil le respect des eaux
la tendresse avec ses enfants
la solidité des couples et puis la
solidarité avec les autres membres de
l'humanité merci beaucoup jean veil
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
alors on va parler de sport maintenant
moi le sport je n'aime pas trop sage
plutôt comme churchill nos spots voyait
enfin celui qu'on accueille aujourd'hui
un grand champion qui donne qu'un kit
chèque qui compte les secondos 6-1 2-3 à
au delà de 3 c'est la faute on va parler
de basket basket 3 contre toi 3 ces
trois là moi je suis seul mais j'ai
gagné de toute façon
karim souchu ok on est parti sur le
tabac tu as vingt secondes d'effort 10
secondes de repos on est celle d'envoyer
on change les idées c'est parti jumping
jacks ce
ok on va le doublé sur la deuxième série
on va essayer de faire une alternative
prédateurs diack sans voix un peu plus
c'est parti
on explose on essaie d'aller chercher
beau
on est un peu
les montagnes tombent au bon exercice ça
t'amène gainey ça envoie un peu aussi
ouais c'est parti
ou bien mettre les pieds à côté de moi
parce tu écoutes
soufflez bien j'essaie de récupérer
entre temps
classique huit possibles
on est partis sur des pentes
mains sur les hanches c'est parti on va
se gagner
droit
mais là ça envoie c'est bien ça même
chose avec le twist
c'est parti up to it
with
bon
donc
mon premier match
au petit mairie ouais c'est parti
on va chercher plus haut possible
se mettre un petit peu de skip
genou levé c'est parti
on va essayer d'aller chercher un robot
pour aller le plus haut possible
donc on va vraiment faire comme si on
sortait on finit sur la pointe des pieds
le plus fort possible partie on n'aime
pas les pieds du c'est un devoir
chercher le ciel
petit exercice de basket du latéral un
peu c'est parti le type à on a bien le p
le squad sauter
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on fait trembler les jambes
les ménages pour pascal c'est
l'essentiel
enfin dernière à vos fesses on se penche
en avant c'est parti
ça va aller plus haut c'est
super
bon comme vous voyez on peut envoyer une
séance on se met un peu minable c'est
bien ça fait du bien servir la tête je
vais vous en avez besoin comme tout le
monde alors qu'on confinement et puis
tenez bon courage
[Applaudissements]
peut-on sortir de prison oui bien sûr
parce que si c'est dur la sortie c'est
du sûr big up à dos et non la question
c'est peut-on faire autre chose après
avoir travaillé en prison eh bien oui
bonjour moi qui paye au bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député ps mme
vous avez été directeur de prison vous
avez dirigé freine vous avez dirigé
fleury mérogis où rennes et vous
raconter d'ailleurs dans un livre des
hommes et des murs un mur de souvenirs
vous raconter une prise d'otage que vous
avez vécu les mutineries des mouvements
sociaux les suicides et puis aussi les
amours interdites da prison c'est le
lieu de tous les possibles en fait je ne
sais pas si c'est le lieu de tous les
possibles mais une prison c'est avant
tout une communauté d'hommes ou de
femmes et et je pense que tout ce qu'on
peut observer quelques fois à
l'extérieur dans les comportements on
peut l'observer aussi dans la prison là
moi à sa place en prison oui bien sûr il
y a effectivement des relations
affectives qui se font qu'y sodexo qui
se défont il ya du respect de l'intimité
également c'est tout cela également
l'enfermement et d'ailleurs je dirais
c'est tant mieux ça humanise en réalité
des relations si tout est froid si tout
est technique et bien il n'ya pas
d'humanisation et moi je pense que la
prison doit être humaine vous parlez
dans votre livre d'amour interdite c'est
quoi des amours interdites des relations
affectives entre détenus ce soit lorsque
j'étais à rennes au centre pénitentiaire
qui héberge des femmes ou des
établissements qui hébergeait des hommes
ça j'ai pu observer même si ses cachets
même si on le dit pas même si
effectivement
il ya la suspicion sur ce sujet là c'est
un sujet tabou l'amour en prison et puis
il y avait eu des relations affectives
également en train personnel et puis un
détenu une des cils c'est déjà arrivé et
moi dans mes fonctions j'ai dû traiter
ces problèmes délicats est-ce que vous
militez pour l'autorisation dé des
relations sexuelles en prison alors ça
existe déjà oui avec les unités de vie
familiale et moi j'étais partisan de ces
unités de vie familiale où le détenu
peut accueillir ses proches sa famille
et ses proches donc ça existe et moi
j'ai toujours été favorable à
cela sk le monde politique ça va quoi il
parle quand il parle de présents
j'espère que oui mais de plus en plus de
députés c'est intéressant priso d'une
part on a fait évoluer la législation
parce que maintenant un député peut
aller dans toutes les prisons eux s'ils
souhaitent visiter une prison il peut se
déplacer à n'importe quelle heure de la
journée et donc beaucoup de députés
l'ont fait notamment lorsqu'ils ont une
prison dans dans leur circonscription
oui mais joachim fried et au pardon se
doute pas une seule seconde de votre
sincérité ma faim depuis des années 50
on sait que nos prisons sont une honte
il ne se passe rien alors je dirais que
certaines prisons c'est une ronde n'est
pas tout parce qu'il ya eu quand même
des constructions nouvelles il ya eu des
établissements qui ont été construits ce
qui est difficile pour moi en tout cas
c'est le fait que on n'est berges
plusieurs détenus dans une seule cellule
quelquefois qui dépasse pas 9 mètres
carrés et ça c'est pour moi inacceptable
qu'est ce que vous avez vu plus beau en
prison j'ai un caillou j'ai vu d'une
part des personnels
totalement dévoué parce que les
personnels ils ont une mission difficile
compliqué souvent pendant très longtemps
là leur fonction n'était pas valorisées
quelquefois on avait même honte de dire
qu'on travaille en prison et j'ai vu eux
des personnels extraordinaire et puis
également ce qui m'a rendu également
très optimiste c'est la façon dont
certains détenus ont pu évoluer à
travers une activité de formation à
travers du théâtre je crois à la culture
à la culture et on les a vus se
transformer ce qui a facilité à mon avis
leur insertion et ça pour moi c'est un
grand succès également est ce que vous
auriez un conseil de lecture jakin oui
j'ai j'ai apporté un livre parce que
si le livre d'alice zeniter l'art de
parts de paix c'est une histoire qui m'a
touché
parce que l'héroïne de ce roman naïma
recherche un petit peu la vie de de son
grand-père de son père parce qu'il ya eu
une espèce de rupture et bien c'est
c'est la recherche de notre histoire de
notre identité et dans les prisons vous
avez beaucoup de données ou qui
recherchent un petit peu leur histoire
parce que ils sont issus de plusieurs
continents parce qu'ils ont une histoire
difficile compliquée avec leurs familles
est ce cet ouvrage est une grande leçon
de liberté mais également dit mme annie
t c'est pour ça que je le recommande à
tous d'ailleurs aussi bien pour les
personnels que pour les mercis joachim
failli remercie beaucoup n'obtient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
calais
on se borne à l'adresse mail bernard et
didier
[Applaudissements]
alfie be
[Musique]
nous
je pense aux gens seuls
partis de vous
j'espère pas tout le monde dans une
solitude
confiné avec cette menace invisible
quelles fussent
je pense
[Musique]
c'est qu'ils sont dans ma mètres carrés
oissel
ceux qui sont en prison si évidemment
ce sont assez ancienne mais qui parle de
matière mais le solitude aussi
[Musique]
une impasse oman je suis mutuelle et
tout d'écorcher
[Musique]
comme un chat triste perdu sur la liste
des hommes j'ai trouvé
mais carcéral convention les dalles mais
celui glacé
allez venir soleil et sourire
sur l'autre côté
[Musique]
oh
ces murs et grillages ses portes et ses
plages ses couloirs ses clés
cette solitude si dur et si on peut la
toucher
ce rayon de lune sur le seul à lui
isa j'oublie
[Musique]
de celui que terre des tirs sur sa
chaîne
comme elle ou blessés
[Musique]
on
pas craqué
[Musique]
blues
je sais
il qu on couchait
[Musique]
ils ont fermé la barre d'acier
bettini
où
pas pleurer
[Musique]
betty
faut pas tremblé
où
je sais
tu vas rester
mouais
plus tu réveilles
jamais
[Musique]
j'te dis je t'aime en secours prennent
dans ce long baiser
j'ai ma frangine juste une féminine que
savait rien
je me donne la force des mots et des
notes pour réchauffer
je vais la voile
les prisons centrales
les maisons d'arrêt
[Musique]
je n'ai pas sommeil je fumais robert
léger composé loup
les chansons d'amour une chanson ce coup
pour l'autre côté
pour ceux que l'on jette dans les hauts
lieux dans l'obscurité
pendant que les gendarmes au fond du
confort
sans se réveiller
[Musique]
crapule
meetic
pas plonger
[Musique]
et
je sais
ils t'ont coucher
[Musique]
écrit
il ont fermé leur bar basque
ultime
voix
blu ray
[Musique]
betty
bonjour
[Musique]
tu sais
on se retrouve
l'or
ailleurs
en plein soleil ou
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est françois fait pis y met un truc
donne à lui
vive le petit commerce
will and norman on a dû arrêter le
tournage à parce qu'il pleut des trombes
en fait du coup on s'est replié à la
méthode ont des rues descartes non la
méthode c'est un bar restaurant bah oui
c'est ouvert il faisait l'inventaire
l'on en est la preuve non je voulais
balle là j'allais faire le lancement
d'augustin pour la petite bibliothèque
c'est ce garçon livi pense littérature
délire tatoué sur ses bras il parle de
chansons tiens d'ailleurs écouter
voilà c'est ça joni mitchell aux caisses
view avec un peu de chance on aurait pu
voir ses bras et nous emmène dans sa
bibliothèque non c'est augustin augustin
trapenard
non mais je tends pas plus là ghislaine
je t'entends plus
salut à toutes et à tous je m'appelle
augustin et je vais vous parler d'un
livre parce que c'est la seule chose que
je sais faire dans la vie alors pourquoi
je parle de livres depuis 15-20 ans
maintenant mais parce j'ai envie de
partager la force va tout simplement
qu'un livre peut apporter que ça a pu
m'apporter à moi un livre ça peut
éclairer le monde parfois ça peut
éclairer l'avis éclairé
comportement un événement un sentiment
mais moi par exemple j'ai appris à gérer
ma jalousie en amour avec la littérature
alif ça peut aussi aider à sortir de soi
à s'évader le temps de la lecture de
trois quatre cinq heures de rencontrer
une autre époque un autre lieu d'autres
personnes d'autres expériences et puis
un livre parfois tout simplement ça doit
être beau ça peut vous transporter et
pour longtemps car évidemment c'est très
rare qu'un livre rencontre ces trois
vertus de la littérature des ça arrive
ça m'est arrivé pour le livre tour je
vais vous parler aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle martin eden de jack london qui
est un livre qui a été publié en 1909
jackson vous connaissez peut-être c'est
un romancier américain qui a écrit la
tête la forêt qui a écrit croc blanc des
livres que vous avez pu lire quand vous
étiez en feu où vous avez ou dont vous
avez pu voir les adaptations au cinéma
ça c'est son livre le plus intime martin
eden et c'est peut être l'un des plus
beaux disques et jamais été écrit pour
moi martin eden c'est un marin qui a une
vingtaine d'années et qui vient vraiment
de rien il à s'élever socialement pour
conquérir la femme qu'il aime il a
essayé de devenir écrivain alors ils
traînent dans les milieux de la culture
il va lui arriver à des galères il va
vivre une vie de bohème des tragédies
aussi mais ils sont amusé il s'en sort
toujours et comme c'est un génie et il
va devenir écrivain vers un écrivain à
succès mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il restera toujours un outsider
martin eden quelqu'un qui sait d'où il
vient qui se reconnaît pas attendre
milieu qu'il a conquis et ça je trouve
ça absolument passionnant parce que du
coup ils regardent la bourgeoisie avec
beaucoup d'ironie avec une certaine
mélancolie aussi avec eux beaucoup
d'esprit critique 1 qu'est ce qui va
faire pour ne pas oublier d'où il vient
évidemment je vous raconte rien mais ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que c'est
une des plus belles fins de tous les
romans qui m'est donnée était à lire
dans ma vie c'est un livre qui nous
apportera à mon avis de la lumière qui
vous apportera aussi une évasion pendant
un moment donné et surtout c'est un
livre qui va vous émouvoir parce qu'il
est absolument bouleversant
en ce moment où la visite sont rares ou
impossible je serais content que vous
lisiez coup le partager avec moi je vous
embrasse de loin ce que c'est autorisé
[Applaudissements]
après le chef marx c'est un mousquetaire
qui nous donne rendez-vous en cuisine
deux étoiles toujours nous avons rendez
vous avec un chef qui vient de marseille
michel portos ce bonjour michel portos
chef de cuisine à marseille aujourd'hui
une recette facile à réaliser en
détention cette recette nomme soupe de
riz moules au curry et condiments cette
recette est fait à base de
riz rond un cube de légumes une gousse
d'ail un peu du curry
ducassy déshydraté ou du persil frais un
petit peu d'huile d'olive
quelques moules décortiquées et enfin
quelques 4 on va y aller vous mettez du
riz dans vos casseroles on va y ajouter
dix fois le volume de riz en eau
et là on est en chauffe
on va remuer délicatement avec la
cuillère au début afin d'éviter que le
riz accroche au fond de la casserole
on vient y ajouter le bouillon de
légumes en cubes
au bout de environ 30 35 voire 40
minutes on va obtenir
ceci
voici la soupe de riz
cuite et qui est prête à l'emploi
voyez c'est pas très compliqué
nous allons procéder à la garniture on
récupère quelques moules décortiquées
comme ceux ci
on vient y mettre un petit peu de curry
à votre bon goût en fonction de votre
palais
un petit peu de poudre de persil
quelques 4
un petit peu d'huile d'olive
et on faire on va tâcher ou émincés un
petit peu d'ail
on vient rajouter ça à notre préparation
délicatement
on vient mélanger l'ensemble
comme ceux ci
et on obtient nos moules agrémenté
d'huile d'olive 2 4 un petit peu d'ail
ce que l'on va pouvoir servir avec notre
soupe
en fait
on va rajouter notre préparation
[Musique]
et vous aussi
bonne dégustation
[Musique]
alors qu'y at-il au menu de leur chiffre
de la semaine
blague
l'art chiffre de la semaine c'est ce
moment de télévision qu'on a choisi de
vous montrer il s'agit de l'humoriste
pierre desproges pourquoi pierre
desproges parce que la vie est plus
grande que la fission pierre desproges
qui était humoriste avait réussi à se
mettre à dos l'ennemi public numéro un
jacques mesrine qui une fois arrivé en
prison est arrêté avait été vexé par un
truc avait dit pierre desproges et lui
écrit je n'ai aucune rancune contre vous
si j'en avais eu le problème aurait été
vite réglé
bien nous allons retrouver cette
interview mythique de pierre desproges
dans la non moins mythique émission d'
apostrophes commentée par le non moins
mythique bernard pivot juste après je
vais prendre un carré de porc braisé
dans mes rêves l'établissement est fermé
[Applaudissements]
bon alors vous avez vous avez de solides
de haine oui solidays alors il ya bon je
vais lire le petit passage là parce que
la voulait résumer les coiffeurs sont
l'élément le plus totalement inutiles
d'une nation avec les militaires les
académiciens julio iglesias et des
crottes sur les trottoirs bon alors avec
les ressorts pourquoi parce que j'ai
horreur qu'on me traite pas de la tête
par derrière on me racontant des
conneries dans le dos
c'est l'émission vous leur en voulez pas
ce qu'il faut c'est de la langue comme
si elle était morte alors que c'est
quelque chose de vivant on en a la
preuve ici aujourd'hui vous dit des
choses très graves si on les traitait de
parasites de la société de vieux
croûtons vieilles tiges creuses guignols
vert pomme avec des chapeaux à plumes à
la con une épée de panneaux
sur une faute d'impression
ce sont des querelles des ddn stérile je
suis pas quelqu'un de haineux simplement
j'aime bien le mot aussi et puis quand
je parte sur une idée par une plaine du
coiffeur de l'académicien je pousse à
bout c'est une caricature un peu avec
mes faibles moyens comme les caricatures
de mort choix non lieu soit avec des
prêts c'est avec des mots voilà pourquoi
la crotte de chien parce que brave de
marseille parce que merde
que les ellipses et julio iglesias alors
maintenant l'objet médias c'est
quelqu'un cela vous met bien compris
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup ah
bon c'est dommage qu'ils chantent c'est
tout
[Rires]
ce que je retiens quand même c'est que
il dit à un moment qu'il n'a pas de
haine ça c'est très très important parce
que souvent on pense que les humoristes
surtout ceux qui ont la dent dure ils
ont ils sauvé nommé non pas du tout des
proches des ponts je n'ai pas et ne nous
simplement il et il s'amuse il a et
il a de l'ironie il a du mordant et
puis ils s'amusent ils s'amusent tout ce
qu'ils disent est vrai qu'elle est
française qui complètement délirant est
à c'est assez drôle certains disaient
ils ne respectent rien oui bien sûr
qu'ils respectent rien et rien avec avec
7,7 esprits parisiens conduira où
l'esprit français comme vous voudrez
qu'il avait rien d'académique ça c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire mais qui fit
ya cet esprit fait sa renommée est
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup de
d'écrivains de l'est de son époque que
plus plus célébré que lui et sont
oubliées mais lui des proches eh bien
ils continueront continue de le lire et
c'est très bien aussi
[Applaudissements]
goyer ne pouvez pas savoir comme ça nous
a fait plaisir
ça
se sent roulettes
merci merci beaucoup merci infiniment
merci à vous qui nous avez écrit de
partout de toutes les maisons d'arrêt de
tous les centres pénitenciers merci à
vous tous évidemment on lit tout vos
lettres évidemment on va vous répondre
mais franchement je peux vous le dire
ils font les malins parce que derrière
vous film mais franchement qu'est ce que
ça nous a fait plaisir qu'est ce que ça
vous fait plaisir ça nous a un
probablement émis alors je vais vous
lire un extrait de la lettre d'amis et
je remercie vraiment du fond du coeur
tous les autres dont j'ai les prénoms je
remercie nordine je remercie renault je
remercie jean yves chay remercie
mustafar je vous remercie donc bien
également et donc à mine vous nous
écrivez j'ai eu mes 20 ans ici en
détention le 7 mars je suis incarcéré
pour trafic de stups et port d'armes à
feu je ne vous écris pas pour me vanter
mais que pour que certains réalisent que
prison n'est pas synonyme d'un culte ou
de rejeter de la société la prison c'est
très très dur c'est comme si tu étais
mort sauf que là tu vois qui vient poser
des fleurs sur ta tombe personne ne
pense à moi à part ma mère et ma petite
amie
les gens sur qui j'avais cru pouvoir
compter monte abandonnés chaque jour je
me lève avec la boule au ventre la
pression qui est sur moi est incroyable
je n'ai tué personne je suis un gamin 20
ans ces jeunes je n'ai rien à faire ici
à part perdre mon temps alors pour faire
passer le temps je lis la prison
certains la voient comme une fierté pas
moi tout le monde parle de toi à
l'extérieur ta mère pleure tu perds ton
temps les jours se ressemblent tous
c'est presque une déshumanisation
moi je ne suis pas bien ici je serai
mieux chez moins qu entre ses quatre
murs il pense que la prison est la
solution miracle alors que la réalité
c'est que ça te rend pire merci de nous
écrire vous pouvez continuer de le faire
à lcp sans s'être l'université et 106
l'université 75007 paris si vous avez
des message à envoyer aux personnes qui
sont détenues vous pouvez le faire sur
des confinement at lire pour en sortir
point org ou alors sur twitter as tu des
confiné merci infiniment ça nous a
touchés droite au coeur et du coup vous
avez un message personnel qui vous vient
de yannick noah bonjour à tous
c'est le yannick ceux qui ne m'ont pas
reconnu ces voix là je voulais vous
faire ce petit message je pense est une
très belle initiative
je pense souvent à vous je pense souvent
ces moments que j'ai pu passer avec
certains d'entre vous lors de rencontres
lors de concerts des changes était
vraiment très très fort
j'ai toujours été très sensible à ce qui
se passait dans
le monde carcéral
et voilà je voulais apporter un petit
peu m'en ont porté un et ma pierre à
l'édifice
[Musique]
finir elle rencontre des détenus des
hommes et des femmes est en fait après
la chose qui m'avez vraiment touché
c'était que en fait mais je rencontre
pas des détenus je rencontre des frères
des soeurs moi
aussi je me dis il ya tellement des
moments où peut être au mauvais endroit
au mauvais moment faire le mauvais choix
et que voilà la société nous fait payer
mais à la fin nous reste des êtres
humains on fait tous des erreurs et donc
ouais la démarche pour moi c'était de
venir mettre un petit peu essayé à mon
petit niveau de d'année un petit peu
d'humanité
rencontrait des frères et les soeurs
voilà à discuter
rigoler
chanter même danser voilà je vais passer
des moments très forts donc dans ce
moment de confinement où on est confiné
à la maison je sais que pour vous la
plupart ça doit tellement difficile donc
même un petit message voilà c'est juste
une petite respiration sa fille qu'il ya
des gens dehors beaucoup de gens dehors
qui pense à vous et
les
souvenirs plus récents sont très très
fort et j'ai l'occasion parfois de
rencontrer certains d'entre vous à la
sortie c'était des moments donc que je
n'oublierai jamais la des gens de vous
certaines des familles qui m'ont aussi
donné des témoignages très très ému ce
très fort voilà parce que on et voilà on
fait partie d'une bonne famille
aujourd'hui plus que jamais donc je vous
souhaite vraiment beaucoup de courage à
vous voilà je pense à vous il ya plein
de gens qui pensent à vous je me fais
leur porte parole ils ont pas la
possibilité de vous parler comme ça on
dit là comme je le fais donc je suis je
parle aussi en leur nom
soyez forts et courageux
c'est dur très dur mentalement donc
voila vous embrasse à tous pis
alors mesdames mais si ça lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ce que s'est inscrit à un speed
c'est un personnel pénitentiaire
voilà voilà c'est ça bouge je pensais
que c'était une après midi si on doit
ces 117 mais pas du tout vous qui êtes
dans les murs vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un spip bien entendu et nous allons
tout de suite en retrouver un salut
bonjour un saint denis bois bonjour
bonjour je viens dire qu'un spip c'était
une abréviation de récession 17h20
drones on sait faire tout à fait ça
n'ont alors le spip donc services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et probation
ciel vous voulez là schématiquement
c'est la deuxième entité qui composent
l'administration pénitentiaire alors
vous êtes directeur du spip des landes
est ce que je peux dire que je peut le
résumer comme ça vous êtes le trait
d'union entre ce qu'il ya dedans et
dehors c'est ça c'est exactement ça
c'est vraiment le lien dedans dehors le
spitz à la fois on est dans les
établissements pénitentiaires est à la
fois on prend les mesures en milieu
ouvert et très souvent des personnes qui
ont été incarcérés lorsqu'elles sortent
aussi une continuité de suivi en milieu
ouvert donc c'est exactement ça c'est à
dire que tout au long du suivi que ce
soit en milieu fermé ou en milieu ouvert
il ya une évaluation continue de la
personne à une évaluation à la fois
sociales criminologique et on a des
échanges réguliers avec les magistrats
pour les aider à prendre leur décision
c'est vous vinson qui gérait les sorties
et donc en ce moment c'est beaucoup de
boulot on est débordés mais on arrive à
faire face effectivement puisque de
nouvelles dispositions et et ont été
prises pour favoriser des libérations
anticipées dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire actuelle donc effectivement on
est sur le front pour essayer de gérer
au mieux ses sorties car si on favorise
les sorties pour faire baisser la
population carcérale on ne le fait pas
n'importe comment l'idée c'est quand
même que la personne qui sortent sortent
avec un hébergement sortent avec un
suivi et que toutes les dispositions
étaient prises en amont pour que cette
sortie soit une réussite même dans un
cadre accéléré comme actuellement et
quand vous dites ça c'était que c'est
vous qui êtes en charge de trouver le
logement et le travail alors très
concrètement actuellement un travail vu
la situation c'est une mission a
excessivement complexe on se concentre
sur l'hébergement les textes indiquent
clairement que la priorité c'est un
hébergement pour que des sorties puisse
se réaliser dans des conditions à peu
près acceptable donc voilà on met tous
les efforts sur la recherche
d'hébergements actuellement est ce que
vous vous recruté par exemple vincent
d'indy bois en ce moment alors il ya un
plan un plan national qui a été a été
lancée par la démonstration
pénitentiaire de recrutement on prévoit
de recruter 1500 personnels
supplémentaires dans les prochaines
années est-ce que vous avez vu en prison
des gens qu'il n'y avait pas leur place
alors c'est compliqué de répondre à
cette question ce dont on est sûr c'est
que parfois des courtes peines
d'emprisonnement
peuvent finalement être un facteur de
récidive ça s'est il ya une forme de
consensus là dessus c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on essaie de participer
avec les juridictions au développement
des aménagements de peine des logements
justement pour certaines incarcérations
de courte durée qui peuvent engendrer
des problématiques considérable il faut
quelle qualité pour faire ce métier de
spip très simplement il faut des
qualités humaines parce que c'est on
travaille avec de l'humain tous les
jours on est confronté à des
problématiques
très complexe voilà on peut on voit des
situations qui peuvent nous toucher
personnellement donc il faut vraiment
aimer le travail humain voilà ça c'est
la qualité principale après il faut des
connaissances juridiques des
connaissances en lien avec le travail
social on est un petit peu au carrefour
de différentes matières
mais la qualité principale c'est aimer
travailler et humain et quand est ce que
vous vous dites bon bah là on a réussi
c'est bon d'être concrètement quand
pendant un certain temps on n'a pas revu
une personne qu'on pouvait bien
connaître merci beaucoup vincent alioua
merci infiniment
à 10 chatte bonne journée avoir acquis
schatz et au revoir à toi l'escaut
je suis de là-bas suivante dead
qu'est ce que tu voulais
gestes-barrières gestes barrières
[Applaudissements]
le mot de la fin mes amis nous allons
donner à un homme extraordinaire qui a
connu la prison l'évasion la cavale et
la rédemption donc forcément notre dame
bonjour david de clos bonjour merci
d'être avec nous comment se passe le
confinement pour vous ben franchement je
dois dire jusque le que je le vis
vraiment bien parce que avec tout ce que
j'ai traversé dans ma vie j'ai quand
même fait 10 ans de prison en tout cinq
ans de cavale est donc là ce que je dis
toujours c'est que le plus important
c'est pas attrapé le virus je le prends
super bien et surtout que j'ai je
reprends mes habitudes en mieux parce
que je suis en prison mais comme quand
j'étais en prison je fais en sorte que
ce possible il faut raconter que c'est
fou ce que vous avez fait pendant votre
cavale vous avez trouvé un appart vous
avez évidemment avec une nouvelle
identité trouver un boulot et vous êtes
monté sur scène pendant la cavale est ce
que le système vous a aidé à sortir de
la délinquance ça vient de nous en
priorité et cette force et bien ensuite
on va faire qu'on va faire des belles
rencontres bien sûr on va faire des
rencontres des pas des portes qui se
ferment faut pas six peut pas s'y
arrêter mais si on garde cette volonté
c'est trash de d'avoir envie de s'en
sortir on va rencontrer des bols des
pelles personne est là donc on peut pas
dire où on peut y arriver tout seul
c'est cesser le fait de ces rencontres
qui vont faire on va s'en sortir quand
vous allez arrêter de cavaler ya une
juste qui a été fantastique avec
franchement c'est cette juge a été super
elle a été elle a déjà ils ont fait les
recherches pour voir que pour se rendre
compte que je mentais pas que tout était
vrai que j'avais travaillé ça mais de
paris que que je monte sur scène pendant
ma cavale que je fais des spectacles que
je jouais mon spectacle quand elle a vu
que tout était vrai elle l a dit mémé
elle n'en revenait pas elle a dit mais
vous n'avez rien à faire en prison et je
vais vous donnez votre chance moi qui
était classé complètement irrécupérable
j'étais multi multi récidiviste en est à
dix ans de prison et elle m'a donné
cette chance ça m'a laissé sortir en
bois avec le bracelet électronique et
donc doit pas la rater cette chance
david envoie bien vous êtes quelqu un qu
un fort caractère est ce que en prison
vous étiez le même vous étiez comme ça
positif puissant
j'ai toujours été comme ça
en français c'est ma nature j'ai eu des
moments très difficiles en prison mais
ces moments ils sont indescriptibles
c'est on est pris on a le coeur le
ventre c'est une douleur indescriptible
et ces moments là eh bien mon aurait pu
me mettre un genou à terre de faire j'en
ai connu qui se sont suicidés dans des
moments comme ça je repense à eux et est
donc moi je je je prenais tout cette
force en positif j'essayais de 2,2
d'amener cette force à ma femme au
parloir lui montrer que comprendre le
temps l'a pas en prison c'est comprendre
le temps ce toujours se dire rappelé
cinq ans en arrière c'était hier cinq
ans devant ce sera demain se le dire
tout le temps comprendre le temps et
faire en sorte que ce temps soit utile
écrire moi j'écrivais je je je posé les
bases pour mon futur
ce que je voulais faire jeu et j'avais
cette force et puis surtout cette joie
communicative que j'essayais de
communiquer à tout ce que je vois il
n'avait pas le moral je racontais mes
histoires avec humour et dérision je
faisais rire la promenade je veux
redonner le moral à tout le monde et et
voir voir le tout le monde avoir le
moral ça me redonne est mon moral à moi
aussi on 11 galvanisé tous quoi on se
paie j'étais comme un meneur qui portait
est ce qu'il ya un livre un disque qui
vous a aidé à tenir il ya eu deux livres
j'ai dû les lire plusieurs fois
tellement à chaque fois que j'avais une
baisse de moral c'était par exemple
papillon d'henri charrière et au nom de
tous les miens de martin gray quand je
lis les leur histoire je pouvais pas me
plaindre papillon c'est la maison du ban
mais y'a pas que son évasion c'est les
années cachot qui la paye et c'est autre
chose que nos cachot à nous c'était
vraiment la halle à la réclusion que
c'était des années dans le noir et tout
il en a bavé et martin gray est pareil
l'holocauste les voilà au nom de tous
les miens ces livres c'est voilà qui
montent ils tuent les lis tu relèves la
halle à la tête de ses livres tu dis tu
peux pas te plains des tutus fonds
squattant tubes à quoi tu dis waouh
c'est faut y aller
la semaine dernière je te donnait la
parole à loïk le floch prigent qui me
disait avoir coupé tous les contacts
avec les personnes détenues ou les
personnels pénitentiaires parce que
c'était trop douloureux et vous je sens
que j'ai trop trop de messages à
communiquer trop trop trop de choses à
leur dire pour essayer de leur faire
comprendre ce que moi j'ai mis longtemps
à comprendre essayer de leur faire
gagner du temps en comprenant qu'il faut
le mettre leur culot leur talent leur
intelligence dans l'honnêteté qui
déchireront tout donc j'ai plein de
messages à leurs données et je dois
retourner dans ses prisons mais même
dans les écoles les collèges alors on va
partout mais au moins les gens va dans
les prisons et ce qui se passe c'est
c'est tout simplement magique parce
qu'on a vraiment les mots on a vraiment
le la façon de leur parler le spectacle
et fait rire subit du débat et surtout
chose très importante on amène des
victimes avec nous des victimes de
cambriolages d'agression parce que je
suis persuadé que l'on changera les
choses que si on amène ses deux combats
en même temps sinon on va diviser et si
on laisse les victimes sur le côté on
divisera et donc quand on amène les
victimes avec nous
les villes et les détenus se rendre
compte que c'est qu'être une victime et
l'aider et les victimes se rendre compte
que c'est qu'être détenus et et la vie
qu'ils ont eues dans le passé les
changes qui entre eux c'est tout
simplement magique un petit message pour
ceux qui sont dedans aujourd'hui
ben je leur souhaite vraiment vraiment
plein de courage parce que je sais que
les parloirs sont coupées les conditions
des tensions sont très dures mais tenez
le coup mais surtout poser les bases
pour le futur parce que ça va passer la
liberté vous l'avez pas pour l'instant
mais elle va venir elle va venir et
grande force à vous lisez étudiés
préparez votre sortie merci beaucoup de
vie de claude merci beaucoup merci à
vous merci à vous d'avoir pour ce trop
plein de confinement
merci à vue voilà c'est donc sur le pont
et devant notre dame que nous allons
quitter aujourd'hui on se retrouve bien
entendu vent 10 prochain à 19h30 sur lcp
pour des cons fine et d'ici là bien
entendu toutes les rediffs pour vous qui
est détenu à la télévision il ya aussi
pour vous qui êtes dehors et qui avait
internet la chaîne youtube dès le cp on
se retrouve de toute façon la semaine
prochaine merci d'avoir été avec nous
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire merci de
l'avoir fait ça nous a infiniment touché
merci de nous avoir envoyé volet on se
retrouve vendredi à 19h30 françois
dedans ou dehors